it was reaction Fox News contributed Ari
Fleischer and the author of The Coming
collapse of China and the great U.S
China Tech War Gordon Chang Gordon let
me let me start with you about this
um I am watching saber rattling the
likes of which I've never seen before we
may now within hours perhaps days have a
confrontation in the South China Sea
with the Communist Chinese they know
nothing happened when that balloon was
flying all over the continental U.S and
over Alaska's airspace uh they know that
we did nothing when when Russia took
down a drone clearly they have made a
determination that this President is not
going to act that is my take what is
yours
I agree with you Sean because you know
flying that large balloon over our
nuclear weapons sites in other words
they were preparing for a first or
second nuke strike on the U.S that
showed utter disrespect utter disregard
for the United States and they saw the
reactions of the Pentagon to this and
the reactions of the commander-in-chief
and there was complete disarray we could
have shot that balloon down over Alaska
over Canada over uninhabited land and we
didn't do it so there was a failure of
the highest order and we have seen the
collapse of America's position around
the world all of these places that you
mentioned and this is happening because
Biden has gone back on successful
American policies president Trump had
the most successful Middle East policy
of any American president since FDR and
Biden has had the worst Trump should
have gotten a Nobel Peace Prize for the
Abraham Accords but you know of course
the Europeans wouldn't do that
the New York Times but that's a
different story no I I this is this is
so serious to me Gordon what you're
saying and they're obviously Joe Biden
has abdicated the role of the U.S in the
Free World but also the world in general
and now it was clear the Saudi decision
a very conscious decision not only did
they they allow China to broker or deal
with their arch nemesis Iran next to
Syria but now they also reduce the
production of of oil what by a million
three barrels a day which will raise
prices because the U.S is out of the
domestic energy production business
yes and you know president Trump one of
the first things that his National
Security team decided was that the U.S
was going to maintain energy
Independence and we were going to pump
oil and gas and use it to sell to others
and to get them to follow American
policies this was great policy and Biden
has just turned his back on it and
that's why we have the collapse of the
American position we've never seen this
in our lifetimes we're now back at the
Carter era of the U.S Being
um considered the weak person in the
world I mean I I this is
incomprehensible Sean there was a
momentari Fleischer during this
President XI and Vladimir Putin's Summit
at the very end and I know they wanted
this to go viral I know they wanted the
world to see it and that is President XI
saying that we have an opportunity that
we have not seen in over a hundred years
my interpretation of that is they now
want to be the sole dominant superpower
in the world do you agree or disagree
no I think they both want to and
whatever happens that takes down America
that moves us down several notches that
weakens us is all what they want look
this began with Barack Obama's refusal
to uh to enforce a red line against
Syria when Syria moved chemical weapons
it started with a red line in Syria and
it's continued to a balloon with China
it's the weakness of the American
president this did not happen under
Donald Trump and it happens now because
they measure us and they measure Biden
and they see weakness and Sean you just
said it right the failure to take down
the balloon right away and just what the
Russians did over the Black Sea
international territory when they shot
down an American drone what did we do to
respond we sat on our hands
you don't think foreign Nations observe
this not only China and Russia but Iran
and North Korea too and what also then
happens is Nations like Saudi Arabia the
United Arab Emirates are allies in the
Middle East Egypt they start to hedge
their bets they don't think they can
rely or count on America the way they
did when we took out general soleimani
of Iran so they start to Cozy up to
China and the others look when Donald
Trump was in office the Arab Nations
made peace with Israel now they're
playing footsie with China it's because
of Joe Biden and and Gordon let me go
back to you because they're lecturing
the United States and are elected
officials they're telling the our
elected officials that in fact they
can't go visit our Ally Taiwan or there
will be repercussions they didn't even
want speaker McCarthy meeting with the
Taiwanese president in California for
crying out loud they think they can
lecture us and threaten us go to The
Drudge Report China ready to fight uh it
goes on rare carrier confrontation
Showdown with U.S Navy I can't imagine
for a second that that would ever happen
with Donald J Trump as president because
I genuinely think they feared him and
they had a belief that he meant it that
he might be crazy enough to do it and
that fear was a great motivator to
prevent them from doing a lot of this
stuff
yes it certainly is and Sean you
mentioned what's going on in the Taiwan
Strait right now there are three large
navies that are in close proximity to
each other China's chylons and ours this
is exceedingly dangerous we have seen
China with these dangerous intercepts of
American planes and international
airspace and it shows again that
disrespect for the U.S that means you
know you have a Chinese military Corps
they know better but they do want to go
to war and we have a political system in
China that is actually encouraging Xi
Jinping to do the same thing this is
dangerous and Biden and the Pentagon
they have no clue as to what's occurring
inside China and Ari Fleischer I don't
think Joe Biden will do a thing if they
confront our carrier in in that area
I'm not sure about that I think that if
there is military action taking against
one of our Naval warships he'll have no
choice how could he just sit there
silently and let that happen let a spy
balloon fly all across the U.S and not
lift a finger
yeah I think there's a difference
between that and an active naval ship
that has United States Personnel aboard
what if they just what if they just try
a blockade I bet you Joe Biden would
turn around
That's how little faith I have yeah
blockade is different Sean and I would
worry about that I would worry about Joe
Biden's fortitude about a blockade yeah
he doesn't even know what it is
Ari Fleischer thank you give it up Ari
Gordon Chang thank you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else